elon musk great to see you how are you
good how are you
i mean we're here at the texas
gigafactory the day before this thing
opens it's been pretty crazy out there
thank you so much for making time very
busy day i would love you to help us
kind of cast our minds i don't know 10
20 maybe 30 years into the future
and
and help us try to picture
what it would take to build a future
that's worth getting excited about
you've often said the last time you
spoke at ted you said that that was
really just a big driver it's you know
you talk about lots of other reasons to
do the what you're doing but
fundamentally
you
want
to think about the future and not think
that it sucks yeah absolutely i think in
general um you know there's there's a
lot of discussion of like this problem
with that problem and a lot of people
are
uh
sad about the future and then that
they're
uh
pessimistic and and i think
uh
this is this is uh
this is not not great i mean we really
want to
wake up in the morning and and look
forward to the future we want to be
excited about uh
what's going to happen
um and um
and and life cannot simply be about uh
sort of solving one miserable problem
after another
so if you look forward 30 years you know
this year 20 the year 2050 has been
labeled by
scientists as this kind of
almost like this doomsday deadline on
climate there's a consensus of
scientists at large consensus of
scientists who believe that if we
haven't completely uh eliminated
greenhouse gases or offset them
completely by 2050
effectively we're inviting climate
catastrophe do you believe there is a
pathway to avoid that catastrophe and
what would it look like
yeah yeah so
um
i am not one of the doomsday people
which makes price uh
i i actually think we're on a good path
um i but at the same time i i want to
want us to caution against complacency
so so long as we are not complacent as
long as we are have a high sense of
urgency about moving towards a
sustainable
uh energy economy then i think things
will be fine
um
so i i can't emphasize that enough so
long as we
uh push hard uh and i'm not complacent
um
the future's gonna be great don't worry
about it
i mean worry about it but if you worry
about it ironically it will be a
self-unfulfilling prophecy um so
like there are there are three elements
to a sustainable energy future uh one is
of sustainable energy generation which
is primarily wind and solar there's also
hydro
geothermal
i'm actually pro nuclear
i think i think beautifully is fine
and that but it's going to be primarily
solar and wind
as these
uh
the the primary generators advantage the
second part is you need batteries to
store uh the solar and wind energy
because the sun doesn't shine all the
time the wind doesn't blow all the time
so you need a lot of stationary battery
packs
and then you need electric transport so
electric cars electric planes boats
and then uh ultimately
it's not really possible to make
electric rockets but you can make the
propellant used in in rockets uh using
sustainable energy right so
ultimately we can have a fully
sustainable energy
economy uh and um
and it's those three things solar wind
uh stationary battery pack electric
vehicles so so then like what what are
the limiting factors on progress the
limiting factor really will be uh
battery cell production
so that's that's gonna that's gonna
really be the fundamental rate driver
and then whatever the slowest element of
the whole uh
lithium-ion battery cell
supply chain from mining
and the many steps of refining to
ultimately creating a battery cell
and putting it into a pack that will be
the limiting factor on progress towards
sustainability all right so we need to
talk more about batteries because the
key thing that i want to understand like
there seems to be a scaling issue here
that is kind of amazing and alarming you
have said that you have calculated
that the amount of battery production
that the world needs for sustainability
is
300 terawatt hours of batteries if
that's the
rough
very rough numbers then i certainly
would invite others to
check our calculations because they may
arrive at a different at different
conclusions but
in order to
transition uh not just
current electricity production but also
uh heating
and transport
which roughly triples the amount of
electricity that you need uh
it amounts to approximately 300 terawatt
hours of installed capacity so we need
to give people a sense of
how big a task that is i mean here we
are the gigafactory you know this is
what this is
one of the biggest buildings in the
world um
when
what i've read and tell me if this is
still right is that the goal here is to
eventually produce
um 100 gigawatt hours of batteries here
a year
we'll probably do more than that but
yes that's
hopefully we get there within a couple
of years right
but i mean that so that is
1.1 terawatt hours
but that's still 1 100th of what's
needed how much of the rest of that 100
is is tesla planning to take on between
let's say between now and
20 30 20 40
when when uh you know we really need to
see the scale up happen
i mean these are just guesses i mean um
so please position hold me to these
things it's not like this is like uh
some what does happen is i'll i'll i'll
make some like you know best guess and
then people will
in five years there'll be some jerk that
writes an article elon said this would
happen
and it didn't happen he's a liar and a
fool yeah it's very annoying when that
happens uh
so these are just guesses this is a
conversation right um
i i like i think tesla probably ends up
doing 10
of that uh
roughly 20 let's say 2050 we have this
amazing
you know 100 sustainable electric grid
made up of you know some mixture of the
the sustainable energy sources you
talked about that
that same grid probably is offering the
world really low cost energy isn't it
compared compared with now yeah and i'm
curious about like
should people are people entitled to get
a little bit excited about the
possibilities of that that world people
should be optimistic about the future
the
humanity will solve sustainable energy
it will happen if we are you know
continue to to push hard the future is
bright
um and good from an energy standpoint
and then it will be possible to also use
that that energy to do carbon
sequestration uh it takes a lot of
energy to pull carbon out of the
atmosphere just as a because in in
putting it in the atmosphere it release
energy so now you know obviously in
order to pull it out you need to
use a lot of energy but if you've got
a lot of sustainable energy from wind
and solar uh you can actually sequester
carbon so you can reverse the co2 uh
parts per million of the atmosphere and
and oceans um and and also uh you can
really have as much freshwater
freshwater as you want
earth is mostly water we should call
earth water it's 70 water by surface
area now most that seawater but it's
still it's like uh we just haven't been
on the bit that's land right
and with energy you can turn sea water
into yes
irrigating water or whatever water
absolutely yeah um at very low cost um
things will be good things things will
be good yes and also there's other
benefits right to this non-fossil fuel
world where where the air is cleaner and
uh yes exactly yeah yeah because like
like when you when you burn fossil fuels
there's al there's all these like uh
side reactions and and and toxic gases
of various kinds um and like like
sort of uh little particulates that that
are bad for your lungs like there's all
sorts of bad things that are happening
that will go away and and the sky will
be cleaner and
quieter uh fear's gonna be good i want
us to switch now to to think a bit about
artificial intelligence and but the
segway there
look you mentioned how annoying it is
when people
call you up for bad predictions in the
past so
i'm i'm possibly going to be um uh
annoying now but um i i i'm curious
about your timelines and how you predict
and how come some things are so
amazingly on the money and some aren't
so when it comes to predicting
sales of tesla vehicles for example
i mean you've kind of been amazing i
think in 2014
when tesla had sold that year 60 000
cars
you said 2020 i think we will do half a
million a year yeah we did almost
exactly half a million you did almost
exactly half a minute you were scoffed
in 2014 because no one yeah since
henry ford with the model t had had come
close to that kind of growth rate yeah
for four cars
you were scoffed and you actually hit
500 000 cars and 510 000 or whatever
produced
but five years ago
last time you came to ted we um i asked
you about full self driving and um you
said yep this very year where i am
confident that we will have a car going
from la to new york
without any intervention yeah i i don't
want to blow your mind but i'm not
always right
um
so talk talk what's the difference
between those two why
why has full self driving in particular
been so hard to predict i mean the thing
that really got me and i think is going
to get a lot of other people is that
there are just so many false stones with
with self-driving um where you think you
think you got the problem uh have a
handle on the problem and then it nope
uh it turns out
uh you just hit a ceiling um and and uh
uh
because what happened
if you if you were to plot the progress
that the progress looks like a log curve
so it's like yeah a series of log curves
so
uh most people don't like groupies i
suppose but it it
shows that it
it it goes it goes up sort of if you
know sort of a fairly straight way and
then it starts tailing off right and and
and you start and there's a kind of
ocean getting diminishing returns
uh yeah and you're like oh this it was
trending up and now it's sort of curving
over and not and and you you start
getting to these what i call a local
local maxima uh where uh you don't
realize basically how dumb you were uh
that's uh and then and then and then it
happens again so
um and uh ultimately um i know these
things in
you know in retrospect they seem obvious
but uh in in order to solve uh full
self-driving uh properly you actually
just you have to solve real-world ai
um
because you said like what are the road
networks designed to to work with
they're designed to work with a
biological neural net to our brains um
and with uh vision our eyes
and so
in order to make it work uh
with computers you basically need uh to
solve real world ai
uh and vision
because because
we we we need
uh
we need cameras and silicon neural nets
uh in order to have to have
self-driving work for a system that was
designed for eyes and biological neural
nets
it you know when you i guess when you
put it that way it's sort of like quite
obvious
that the only way to solve full
self-driving is to solve real world uh
ai and sophisticated vision what do you
feel about the current architecture do
you think you have an architecture now
where where there is
a chance for the logarithmic curve not
to tail off any any time
soon
well i mean
admittedly these these uh may be an
infamous uh last words but i i actually
am confident that we will solve it this
year
uh that we will exceed uh you're like
what the probability
of an accident at what point should you
exceed that of the average person right
um i think we will exceed that this year
what are you seeing behind the scenes
that gives you that confidence
we're almost at the point we have a high
quality
unified vector space like in the
beginning we're trying to
do this with image recognition on
individual uh
images but if you look at one image out
of a video it's actually quite hard to
see what's going on with without a
ambiguity but if you look at it at a
video segment of a few seconds of video
that ambiguity resolves
um so the so the first thing we have to
do is sort of tie all eight cameras
together so they are synchronized so
that all the frames are looked at
simultaneously and labeled
simultaneously by by a one person
because we still need human labeling
um
so so at least they're not labeled at
different times by different people in
different ways um and then
so it's sort of a surround picture then
then a very important part is to add the
time dimension
so so that you you're looking at
surround video
and your labeling surround video
and
this is actually quite difficult to do
from a software standpoint we had to
write our own
labeling tools and then
create
[Music]
an order labeling uh
create order labeling software is to
amplify the efficiency of human labelers
because it's quite hard to label but it
takes in the beginning it was taking
several hours to label a 10 second video
clip this is not
scalable uh so so basically what you
have to have is you have to have
surround video and
the that surround video has to be
primarily uh automatically labeled with
humans just being editors of it and
making slight corrections to the to the
the labeling of the video and then
feeding back those corrections into the
future auto labeler so you get this this
flywheel eventually where the auto
labeler is able to take in vast amounts
of video and with high accuracy
automatically label uh the video for uh
you know cars lane lines drive space
what you're saying is that though that
you you
think
that i mean the result of this is that
you're effectively giving the car a
3d model of the actual objects that are
all around it it knows
what they are and it knows how fast they
are moving and the remaining task is to
yes is to predict
what the quirky behaviors are that that
you know that when a pedestrian is
walking down the road with a smaller
pedestrian that maybe that smaller
pedestrian might do something
unpredictable or like things like that
you have to build into it before you can
really call it safe you basically you
need to have um
uh memory across time and space uh so
what i mean by that is um
if if you uh because you you can't the
memory can't be infinite because it's
using up a lot of of
the computers
around basically uh
so you have to say how much are you
going to try to remember um
but like if it's very common for things
to be occluded so like if you talk about
see a pedestrian walking past a truck
where you saw the pedestrian um
stop on one side of the truck then they
then they're occluded by the truck right
uh you need but but you need to
you would know intuitively okay there's
that pressure is going to pop out the
other side most likely and and
it doesn't know so you need to slow down
i mean a skeptic is going to say that
every year for the last five years
you've you've kind of said well no this
is the year well we're confident that it
will be there in a year or two or you
know like it's it's always been about
that that far away but you're
we've got a new architecture now you're
you're seeing enough improvement behind
the scenes to to make you not certain
but but pretty confident that that this
by by the end of this year what in most
not in every city in every circumstance
but in many
cities and circumstances basically the
car will be able to drive without
interventions safer than a human um yes
i mean the car currently drives me
around austin most the time with no
interventions
so it's not like um
and and we have uh over 100 000 people
in our uh
full-self driving beta program uh so
you can look at the videos that they
post online um okay great um and uh some
of them are great and some of them are a
little terrifying i mean occasionally
the car seems to sort of like veer off
and scare the hell out of people um but
um
it's still better
but but you put that number but you're
behind the scenes looking at the data
you're seeing enough improvement to to
to believe that
at this year timeline is
real yes that's what it seems like i
mean like i said you know we could be
here
talking again in a year it's like well
yeah another year went by and it didn't
happen but i think this i think this is
the year and so in general when when
people talk about elon elon time i mean
it sounds like like you can't just have
a general rule that if you predict that
something will be done in six months
actually what you what we should imagine
is it's going to be a year or it's like
2x or 3x it depends on the type of
prediction some things i guess things
involving software you know ai or
whatever are fundamentally harder to
predict than than others is there an
element that you actually deliberately
make aggressive prediction timelines to
drive people to be ambitious and without
that nothing gets done well i generally
believe in terms of internal timelines
that we want to set set the most
aggressive timeline that we
can um
because it's sort of like a low of gases
expansion where
for schedules where whatever
time you set it's it's not going to be
less than that it's very rare there will
be less than that
um but as far as my predictions are
concerned um what tends to happen in the
media is that they will report all the
wrong ones and ignore all the right ones
right um and uh
or you know when writing an article
about me
i've had a long career in multiple
industries if you if you list my sins i
sound like the worst person on earth but
if you put those against the my you know
the things i've done right it makes much
more sense you know so it's essentially
like the longer you do anything the the
more mistakes that that you will make
cumulatively which if you sum up those
mistakes will sound like uh i'm the
worst predictor
ever but for example for the tesla
vehicle growth uh i i said i think we'll
do 50 percent and we've we've done 80
yes
so
uh but they don't mention that one uh so
i mean i'm not sure what my exact track
record is on predictions they're more
optimistic than pessimistic but they're
not all optimistic um some of them uh
are exceeded uh probably more or later
um but they uh
they they do come true it's very rare
that they do not come true
it's sort of like uh you know
uh
you know if if there's some radical
technology prediction uh
the point is not that it was a few years
late but that it happened at all
that's the that's the more important
part so it's it feels like at some point
in the last year
seeing the progress on
understanding that your the ai the tesla
ai understanding the world around it led
to a kind of an aha moment in tesla
because you really surprised people
recently when you said
probably the most important product
development going on at tesla this year
is this robot optimus yes
many companies out there have tried to
put out these robots they've been
working on them for years and so far no
one has really
cracked it there's no mass adoption
robot in people's homes there are some
in in manufacturing but it like i would
say no one's kind of really
cracked it what
is it something that happened in the
development of full self-driving that
gave you the confidence to say you know
what we could do something special here
yeah exactly so you know it took me a
while to sort of realize that that in
order to solve self-driving you really
needed to solve real world ai um and at
the point which you solve real world ai
for a car which is really a robot on
four wheels uh you can then generalize
that to a robot on legs as well
the the two hard parts i think like it's
not obviously companies like boston
dynamics have shown that it's possible
to make uh
quite compelling sometimes alarming
robots right um
you know so this is from a sensor as an
actuator standpoint it's certainly uh
been demonstrated by many that it's
possible to make a humanoid robot the
thing that the things that are currently
missing are uh
enough intelligence enough intel
intelligence for the robot to navigate
the real world and do useful things um
without being uh explicitly instructed
it is so the missing things are
basically real-world
intelligence and
scaling up manufacturing those are two
things that tesla is very good at and
so then we basically just need to design
the the
specialized actuators and sensors that
are needed for a humanoid robot
people have no idea this is going to be
bigger than the car
so let's dig into
exactly that i mean in one way it's
actually an easier problem than full
self-driving because you instead of an
object going along at 60 miles an hour
which if it gets it wrong someone will
die
this is an object that's engineered to
only go what three or four or five miles
an hour walking speed basically and so a
mistake isn't there aren't lives at
stake there might be embarrassment at
stake it's almost like that yeah it
doesn't take it over and uh
uh
right and murderous now sleep or
something right
but um um but so talk about i mean i i
think the first applications you've
mentioned are probably going to be
manufacturing but eventually the vision
is to to have these available for people
at home correct if you had a robot that
really
understood the 3d architecture of your
house and
knew where every object in that house
was or was supposed to be and could
recognize all those objects i mean that
that's kind of amazing isn't it like
that the kind of thing that you could
ask a robot to do
would be what like tidy up yeah um
absolutely
or
make make dinner i guess mow the lawn
take take a cup of tea to grandma and
show her family pictures and exactly
take care of
my grandmother and make sure yeah
exactly when it could recognize
obviously recognize everyone in the home
yeah could play catch with your kids
yes i mean obviously we need to be
careful this doesn't uh become a
dystopian situation um
like i think one of the things that's
going to be important is to have a
localized rom chip on the
robot that cannot be updated uh over the
air uh where if you for example were to
say stop stop stop that would if anyone
said that then the robot would stop you
know type of thing
and that's not updatable remotely um i
think it's going to be important to have
safety features like that
yeah
that sounds wise and i do think there
should be a regulatory agency for ai
i've said this for many years i don't
love being regulated but i you know i
think this is an important thing for
public safety
let's come back to that but i'm just i i
don't think
many people have really sort of taken
seriously the notion of
you know a a robot at home i mean at the
start of the computing revolution you
know bill gates said there's going to be
a computer in every home and people at
the time said yeah whatever who would
even want that did you know in our
pocket do you think there will be
basically like in say 2050 or whatever
that like a
a robot in most homes is what they will
be and people will i think they'll
probably count on them you'll have your
own butler basically
yeah you'll have your sort of buddy
robot
probably yeah i mean how much of a buddy
do like do you do how many applications
do you thought is there you know can you
have a romantic partner a sex partner i
mean a lot of them probably inevitable
i mean i did promise the internet that i
would make cat girls we'll have we could
make a robot cackle
i mean because everyone's into that
so yeah i i guess uh it'll be what what
whatever people want really you know so
what sort of timeline should we be
thinking about of the first the first
models that are actually made and sold
well
you know the first units that that we
tend to make are
um
for jobs that are dangerous boring
repetitive and things that people don't
want to do and you know i think we'll
have like an interesting prototype
sometime this year we might have
something useful next year but i think
quite likely within at least two years
and then we'll see rapid growth year
over year of the usefulness of the
humanoid robots a decrease in cost and
scaling up production initially just
selling to businesses or when you
picture you you'll sell you'll start
selling them where you can
buy your
parents one for christmas or something
i'd say less than 10 years yeah how how
how
help me on the economics of this so what
what do you picture the cost of one of
these being well i think the cost is
actually not going to be
crazy high um
like less than a car initially things
will be expensive because it'll be new
technology at low production volume the
complexity and cost of a car is greater
than that of a humanoid robot
so i would expect that it's going to be
less than a car or at least equivalent
to a cheap car so even if it starts at
50k within a few years it's down to 20k
or lower or whatever
to and and maybe for home they'll get
much cheaper still but yeah but but
think about the economics of this if you
can
replace a
30 000 40 000 a year worker
which you have to pay every year
with a one-time payment of 25 000
for a robot that can work
longer hours a pretty rapid replacement
of certain types of jobs how worried
should the world be about that
i wouldn't worry about the the sort of
putting people out of a job thing um i
think
we're actually going to have and already
do have a massive shortage of labor so i
i i think we will have
um uh
not not people out of work but actually
still a shortage labor even in the
future uh
but
this really will be a world of abundance
any goods and services
uh will be available to anyone who wants
them that it'll be so cheap to have
goods and services it'll be ridiculous
and presumably it should be possible to
imagine
a bunch of goods and services that can't
profitably be made now but could be made
in in that world courtesy of of
legions of robots yeah um
it will be a world of abundance the only
scarcity that will exist in the future
is that which we decide to create
ourselves as humans okay so ai is is
allowing us to imagine a a differently
powered economy that that will create
this abundance
what are you most worried about going
wrong well like i said
ai and robotics will will bring
um bring out what might be termed the
age of abundance um other people have
used this word um
and and that this is my prediction i'll
be an age of abundance um for everyone
um
the the that i guess there's
uh the the dangers would be the
artificial general intelligence or
digital super intelligence
uh decouples from a collective human
will and uh goes in a direction that for
some reason we don't like of whatever
whatever direction it might go
um
you know that's what sort of the
idea behind neural link is to try to
more tightly couple a collective human
world to
the to digital uh super intelligence um
and also along the way solve and a lot
of um
brain injuries and spinal injuries and
that kind of thing so
even if it doesn't succeed in the
greater goal it will i think it will
succeed in in the uh goal of alleviating
uh
brain and spine damage so the the spirit
there is that if we're going to make
these ais that are so vastly intelligent
we ought to be wired directly to them so
that we ourselves can have the
superpowers more more directly but that
doesn't seem to avoid the risk that
those superpowers might um
turn ugly in an unintended way no i
think it's a risk i agree i i i don't
i'm not saying that i have some
certain uh answer to that risk i'm
i'm just saying like like maybe one of
the things that would
be good for
ensuring that
the future is
one that we want is to more tightly
couple uh
the human world collective human world
to
digital intelligence
um
the the issue that we face here is that
we're already um
a cyborg if you think about it the
computers
uh are an extension of ourselves
um and when we die there's like we have
like a digital ghost you know all of our
text messages and
social media emails and it's quite eerie
actually when someone dies and they're
but everything online is still there
but but you say like what what's the
limitation what what is it that
um
inhibits human machine symbiosis it's
the data rate when you communicate
especially with a phone you're moving
your thumbs right very slowly so you're
moving your two little meat sticks
right at a rate that's maybe
10 bits per second optimistically 100
bits per second
and computers are are communicating at
the gigabit uh level and beyond have you
seen evidence that the technology is
actually working that you've got you've
got a richer sort of higher bandwidth
connection if you like
between like external electronics and a
brain that has been possible before uh
yeah so
the
i mean the fundamental principles of uh
of reading neurons
uh sort of doing read write on neurons
with tiny electrodes um have been
demonstrated for decades um so
it's not like uh this is uh
the concept is new what the the problem
is that there's no product uh that works
well that you can go and uh and buy so
it's it's all sort of in research labs
right um and
it's it's not it's uh
like there's always like some cord
sticking out of your your head and it
it's quite gruesome and it's it's really
um
there's no good product uh that that
that actually does a good job and is
high bandwidth and safe and something
you'd actually that you could buy and
would want to buy so
um
but in it the the way to think of the
neurologic device is kind of like a
fitbit or an apple watch um
that's uh
where we we take out a sort of a small
section of skull about the size of a
quarter
replace that with uh what in many ways
really is very much like um
uh
a fitbit apple watch or or some kind of
smartwatch thing um
uh
and um
and but with with tiny tiny wires very
very very tiny wires tied to wires so
tiny it's hard to even see them um
and it's very important to have very
tiny wires that you uh when they're
implanted they don't they don't damage
the brain how far are you from putting
these into humans
i i well we we have um
put in our fda application uh
to have the uh aspirationally do to the
first uh human implant this year the
first
uses will be for neurological injuries
of different kinds yes but running the
clock forward and imagining when when
people are actually
using these for their own
enhancement let's say and for the
enhancement of the world
how clear are you in your mind as to
what it will
feel like to have one of these inside
your head
well i i do want to emphasize we're
we're at a at an early stage and so
um
it really will be many years before we
have
anything
approximating a high bandwidth
neural interface
that allows for
ai human symbiosis
for many years we will just be solving
uh brain injuries and spinal injuries
from
probably a decade um
that this is not something that will
suddenly one day it'll will have this
incredible sort of
whole brain interface
it's going to be like i said at least a
decade of really just solving um
brain injuries and spinal injuries um
and really i think you can solve a very
wide range of brain injuries including
severe depression uh morbid obesity uh
sleep uh
potentially schizophrenia like a lot of
things that cause
great stress to people
uh restoring uh memory in in all the
people if you can pull that off that is
that that's the app i will sign up for
absolutely i would please hurry actually
yeah
i mean the
the the emails that we get at neurolink
um are heartbreaking um i mean that
they'll send us
just tragic you know you know where
someone was was sort of in the prime of
life and and and they had an accident on
a
motorcycle and and and someone who's 25
is is
you know it can't even feed themselves
and
and this is something we could fix um
but but you have you have said that ai
is one of the things you're most worried
about and that neuralink
may be one of the ways where we can
keep abreast of it or
yes it's it's
there's there's the short-term thing
which i think is helpful on an
individual human level um with injuries
and then the long-term thing is
an attempt to
uh address the civilizational risk of of
ai by
bringing bringing
digital intelligence and biological
intelligence closer together i mean if
you think of how the brain works today
they're really kind of two layers to the
brain there's the limbic system and the
the cortex you've got the kind of animal
brain where it's kind of like the fun
part really um and that's where most of
twitter operates by the way um yeah i
mean we're
i think like tim urban said this like
we're we're like we're like somebody's
you know stuck a computer on a monkey
right um you know so we're like if you
gave a monkey a computer that's our
cortex but we still have a lot of monkey
instincts right so
uh we should then try to rationalize us
no it's not a monkey instinct it's
something more important than that but
it's often just really a monkey instinct
we're in this we're we're just monkeys
with a computer style so stuck in our
brain um
so
um
but even though the cortex is sort of
the smart or the intelligent part of the
brain the thinking part of the brain
um people are quite i've not yet yet met
anyone who wants to delete their limbic
system or their cortex they're quite
happy having both everyone wants both
parts of their brain
and um and people really want their
their phones and their computers which
are really the the tertiary the third
part of of your intelligence it's just
that it's it's
like so the the
bandwidth the rate of communication with
that tertiary layer is uh is slow
and it's just a very tiny stroll
to this tertiary layer and and we want
to make that tiny straw a big highway um
and i i'm definitely not saying that
this is going to solve everything or
this is
you know it's the only thing it's
it's something that that that might be
helpful um and and worst case scenario i
think we we solve some important brain
injury spinal injury issues and that's
still a great outcome right best case
scenario we may discover new human
possibility telepathy you've spoken of
in a social connection with with with
with a loved one
you know full memory yeah um and and
much faster thought process maybe yeah
these things
it's very cool
if ai were to take down
earth we need a plan b let's let's shift
attention to
to space we spoke last time we talked
about reusability and you just
demonstrated that spectacularly for the
first time since then you've gone on to
build this monster rocket starship
um which kind of changes the rules of
the game in in spectacular ways tell us
tell us about starship yes
social is extremely fundamental so the
the holy grail of
of rocketry uh or space transport is
full and rapid reusability this has
never been achieved the closest that
um anything's come is our falcon 9
rocket where we uh
are able to recover the the pres the
first stage the boost stage which is
probably about 60 percent of the cost of
the vehicle
um or of the whole launch uh maybe
seventy percent um and
uh we've not done that over a hundred
times so uh with starship uh we will be
recovering um the entire thing that's at
least that's the goal right um
and and and moreover recovering it in
such a way that it can be immediately
reflowed
uh whereas with falcon 9 we still need
to do some amount of refurbishment to
the booster and to the the fairing
windows nose cone
so um
but with starship the design
uh goal is uh immediate reflight
right so you just
you just refill propellants and and go
again
and
the
this is
gigantic it just just as it would be in
in any other mode of transport and this
and the main design is is and is to
basically take what 100 plus people at a
time plus a bunch of
things that they need to mars
so talk first of all talk about that
piece what what is your latest timeline
one for the first time
a starship goes to mars presumably
without people but just equipment
two with people
three the sort of
okay 100 people at a time let's let's go
sure well and and just put the the cost
thing into perspective
um
the
the cost of
expected cost of starship putting 100
tons into orbit um is significantly less
than what um
it would have cost
or what it did cost to put out our tiny
falcon 1 rocket
into orbit
just as the cost of flying a 747 around
the world uh is is less than the cost of
a small airplane oh you know it's a
smaller print that was thrown away um so
it's really
pretty mind-boggling um that the giant
thing costs less way less than the small
thing so it it doesn't use
sort of exotic
propellants or things that are difficult
to obtain on mars
it
uses methane is fuel and it's primarily
oxygen it's sort of roughly 77 78
oxygen by weight um and
mars has a co2 atmosphere and has water
ice which is co2 plus h2o so you can
make ch4 methane and o2 oxygen on mars
presumably one of the first tassel mars
will be to create
a fuel plant that can create the fuel
for the
trips of many starships yes
and
actually
it's it's mostly going to be an oxygen
plant but but it's it's because it's um
it's it's called 78 oxygen 22 fuel um
but but but the fuel is a simple fuel
that is is easy to create on mars um and
and
many other parts of the solar system so
basically
um it's and it's all propulsive landing
no parachutes um uh nothing thrown away
uh uh
it has a
heat shield that's capable of entering
on earth or mars
um
we could even potentially go to venus
but it's not
you don't want to go there um
venus is hell
almost literally um
but you you could
it's a generalized
method of transport to to anywhere in
the solar system um because the point
which have a propellant deep on mars you
can then travel to the asteroid belt uh
and to the moons of jupiter and then to
saturn and and ultimately anywhere in
the solar system right but you're made
for your main for focus and spacex's
main focus is still
mars like that that is that is the that
is the mission that is that is where
most of the effort
will go
imagining a much broader
array of uses even in the coming
you know
the first decade or so of uses of this
where we could go for example to other
places in the solar system to explore
perhaps
nasa wants to use the rocket for that
reason yeah now so nasa is planning to
use a starship to return to the moon to
return people to the moon um and uh so
we're very honored that nasa's has
chosen us to do this um
uh so
uh but i'm saying it it is it is a
generalized uh it's a it's a general
solution
to
uh getting anywhere in the greater uh
solar system it's not suitable for going
to another star system but it is a
general solution for transport anywhere
in the in the solar system before it can
do any of that it's got to demonstrate
it can get into orbit you know around
earth what's what's what's what's your
latest advice on the on the
timeline for that it's looking promising
for us to have an orbital launch attempt
uh in
in a few months
um
so uh we're actually integrating the uh
we'll be integrating the engines uh into
the booster for the first orbital flight
uh starting in about a week or two
um and um
the
the the launch complex itself is uh
ready to go
so
assuming we get regulatory approval i
think we could have a uh
an orbital launch attempt uh within a
few months and a radical new technology
like this presumably there is real risk
on those early
yeah yeah like i mean the joke i make
all the time is that uh
uh excitement is guaranteed success is
not guaranteed but excitement certainly
is but the last lesson on your timeline
you've slightly put back
the expected date to put
the first human on mars till 2029 i want
to say um yeah i mean so so
uh let's see i mean we we are we have
built a production system for starships
so we're we're we're making a lot of
ships and boosters and how many are you
planning to make actually well we're
currently expecting to um make a
a booster and a ship roughly uh every
well initially roughly every couple
months and hopefully by by the end of
this year um
one every month so it's giant rockets
but a lot and a lot of them just in
terms of talking in terms of rough
orders of magnitude in order to create a
self-sustaining city on mars i i think
the you will need something on the order
of a thousand ships then we just need a
we just need a helen
of of of sparta uh
i guess on the on mars
this this is not in most people's heads
the plan was that launched a thousand
ships
that's that's nice but this is not in
most people's heads this picture that
you have in your mind that so there's
there's basically a two year window you
can only really fly to mars conveniently
every two years yes you are still you
are picturing that during doing the
2030s every couple years something like
a thousand starships take off each
containing 100 or more people that that
that picture is just completely
mind-blowing to me yeah that that sense
of this armada of humans going yeah like
battlestar galactica the fleet of
departs and you think that that it can
basically be funded by people
spending maybe a half a couple hundred
grand on a ticket to
mars is that is that price about where
where it has been
well i think if you say like what's
what's net what's required in order to
get enough people and enough cargo to
mars to
build a self-sustaining city um
and it's where you have an intersection
of sets of people who want to go because
i think only a small
percentage of humanity will want to go
and can afford to go or get sponsorship
in some manner
that intersection of sets i think needs
to be a million people or something like
that um
and so it's what what can a million
people afford or get sponsorship for or
because i think governance will also pay
for it and
people can take out loans and but but i
think at the point of which um
you say okay okay like if if moving to
mars costs are for arguments take um
a hundred thousand dollars then i think
um
you know almost anyone can can work
and save up and and eventually have a
hundred thousand dollars and be able to
go to mars if they want we want to make
it available to anyone who wants to go
yeah um
so
it
and and very important to emphasize that
mars especially in the beginning will
not be luxurious it will be dangerous uh
cramped
difficult hard work
it's kind of like that shackleton ad for
going to the antarctic
which i think is actually not real but
it sounds real and it's cool
it's sort of like the the the sales
pitch for going to mars is it's it's
it's dangerous it's cramped
uh
you might not make it back uh
it's difficult it's hard work that's the
sales pitch right
you will make history
but it'll be glorious right also on that
kind of launch rate you're talking about
over two decades you could get your
million people to
to mars essentially who city is it is it
nasa city is it space existence it's the
people of mars the city
the the the reason for this i mean i
have to say like what we feel like well
why why do this thing it's
i i think this is important uh for
maximizing the probable lifespan of of
humanity or consciousness human
civilization could come to an end for
external reasons like giant meteor or
super volcanoes or
extreme climate change uh
or or
world war three
or you know
any one of a number of reasons um
and and um
but the probable lifespan of of
civilizational consciousness as we know
it
which we should really view as this very
delicate thing like a small candle in a
vast darkness that's that's caught that
that is what appears to be the case
um
we're in this vast darkness of space
and there's this little candle of
consciousness
that's only really come about um after
four and a half billion years
yeah and um it could just go out i think
that's powerful and i think i think a
lot of people will be inspired by that
vision and and the reason so the reason
you need the million people is because
they has to be enough people there to do
everything that you need to survive
really like the the critical threshold
is
um if the ships from earth stop coming
for any reason right um does it does the
mars city die out or or not right and
and so we have to pass that that's
you know people talk about like these
the sort of the great filters the things
that perhaps um
uh you know we talk about the fermi
paradox and where are the aliens and
like well maybe the aliens didn't there
is various great filters that the aliens
didn't pass and and so
they eventually just
ceased to exist and one of the great
filters is becoming a multi-planet
species
so we want to pass that filter
and and uh i'll be long dead before this
is uh
you know a real real thing before before
it happens but i'd like i'd like to at
least see
us make a great progress in this
direction given how tortured the earth
is right now how much we're beating each
other up
shouldn't there be discussions going on
with everyone who is dreaming about mars
to try to say
we've got a once
once
in a civilization's chance yes to make
some new rules here
is that
should someone be trying to lead those
discussions to figure out what it what
it means for this to be the people of
mars this city
well i think ultimately this will be up
to the people of mars to decide what uh
how they want to
rethink society yet there's certainly
risk there um and uh hopefully
the people of mars will be more
enlightened and will not fight amongst
each other too much
i mean i have some recommendations but
which people of mars may choose to
listen to or not and i would advocate
for
more of a direct democracy not a
representative democracy
and laws that are short enough for
people to understand
um and
where it is is harder to create laws
than to get rid of them
coming back a bit nearer term i'd love
you to talk a bit so about some of the
other possibility space that starship
um seems to have created so given given
suddenly we've got this ability to move
100 tons plus into orbit yes
so we've just spent we've just launched
the james webb telescope which is an
incredible thing it's an unbelievable
absolutely
exquisite piece of technology exquisite
piece of technology but people spent two
years trying to figure out how to fold
up this thing it's a three-ton it's a
three-ton telescope we can make it a lot
easier if you've got more volume and
mass well so but let's let's ask a
different question which is what what
what how much more powerful
a telescope could someone design based
on using starship
for example
um
i mean roughly i would say it's probably
an order of magnitude more resolution
if you've got 100 tons and a thousand
cubic meters volume which is roughly
what we have and what about other
exploration through the solar system i
mean i'm i'm you know
europa you're well europe is a great
question mark right so so there's an
ocean there right and what you really
want to do is to drop a submarine into
the yeah i mean maybe there's like some
squid civilization uh under cephalopod
civilization under the ice of europa
that would be pretty interesting i mean
you know if you could take a submarine
to europa and we see pictures of this
thing being devoured by a squid that
would honestly be the happiest moment of
my life very well yeah that would be
what what other
possibilities are out there like it
feels like if you're gonna create a
thousand of these things
they can only fly to mars every two
years what are they doing the rest of
the time it feels like there's this this
right explosion of
possibility that i don't think people
are really thinking about
i mean i don't know if we've certainly
got a long way to go as you alluded to
earlier we still have to get to orbit uh
and and then um after we get to orbit we
have to um
really prove out and refine uh full and
rapid reusability uh that'll take a
moment um and um
but i do think we will solve this i
am i
highly confident we will solve this at
this point um do you ever wake up with
the fear that there's going to be this
hindenburg moment for spacex where
we've had many hindenburg well we've
never had hindenburg moments with people
uh which is very important big
difference right there is
we've blown up quite a few rockets so
this we have a
there's a whole compilation online that
we've put together and let's put
together
uh it's showing rockets are hard um yeah
i mean the sheer amount of energy going
through rocket is it boggles the mind so
yeah you know getting out of both
gravity well is difficult we have a
strong gravity and a thick atmosphere
and and um
and and mars which is
uh less than 40 it's like i think 37 of
earth's gravity um and has a thin
atmosphere uh the ship alone can go all
the way from the surface to mars to the
surface of earth
whereas getting two mars requires a
giant booster and orbital refilling
so
elon
so think more about this incredible
array of things that you're involved
with
i keep seeing
these
synergies
to use a horrible word um but between
them you know for example the robots
you're building from tesla
could possibly be pretty handy on
mars sure um doing some of the dangerous
work and so forth i mean maybe there's a
scenario where your city on mars doesn't
need a million people it needs half a
million people and half a million robots
sure and um that's a possibility maybe
the boring company could play a role
helping create some of the subterranean
dwelling spaces that you might need yeah
um back on planet earth it seems like a
partnership between boring company and
tesla
could offer an unbelievable
deal to a city to say we we will create
view a 3d network of tunnels populated
by robo taxis yeah that will offer fast
low-cost transport to anyone you know
full self-driving may or may not be done
this year and then and in some cities
like someone like mumbai
i suspect won't be done for a decade
some places are more challenging than
others but
today today with what you've got you
could put a 3d
network of tunnels under that oh it was
just an internal that's a sole problem
basically exactly full self-driving is
itself problem so so to me there's
there's amazing synergy there
um you're with with with the starship
you know quinn shot well talked about by
2028 having
from city to city you know transport on
planet yeah this is a a real possibility
it's it's a uh
yeah
the the fastest way to get from one
place to another
it's a long distance is is a rocket it's
right
it's basically icbm right
with the but it has to happen landing
delete the nuke because it's an icbm it
has to land probably offshore yes
it's loud so so
why not have
a tunnel that then connects to the city
yeah
i mean if you're going to go to mars
having a telepathic connection with
loved ones back home even if there's a
time delay i mean
if these are not intended to be
connected by the way they just
but i there certainly could be some
synergies yeah
surely there is a growing argument that
you should actually put all these things
together into
one company and just just have a company
devoted to creating a future that's
exciting
and let a thousand flowers bloom have
you have you been thinking about that
i mean it is tricky because tesla is a
publicly traded company and the
the investor base of
tesla and spacex and and certainly
boring company and neural link are quite
different and when we come to new york
link are our tiny companies just right
comparison the audience
yeah
tesla's got 110 000 people
uh spacex i think is around 12 000
people
uh boring company and neurolink are both
under 200 people
so uh they're little little tiny
companies but they will probably get
bigger in the future they will get
bigger in the future
not that easy to sort of combine these
things um
traditionally you've said that for
spacex especially you don't you wouldn't
want to public because public investors
wouldn't
support um
the craziness of the idea of going to
mars or whatever and yeah you want to
you know making life multi-planetaries
is outside of this the normal uh
time horizon of wall street analysts
say the least i think something's
changed though um what's changed is that
tesla is now so powerful and so big and
throws off so much cash
that you actually could
connect the dots here just tell the
public that x billion dollars a year
whatever your number is will be diverted
to the mars mission i i suspect you'd
have massive interest in that company
and it might it might
unlock a lot more possibility
for you now i mean i would like to give
the public access to
uh ownership of spacex uh but
i mean the thing that
like the the overhead associated with
public company uh
is high um
so
i mean as a public company you're just
constantly sued it does occupy like a
fair bit of um
you know time and effort to uh deal with
these things right but you would still
only have one
public company it would be bigger and
have more things going on but instead of
being on four boards you'd be on one i'm
actually not even on the the neural link
or boring company board oh well yeah and
i i don't really attend the spacex board
meetings
we only have two a year and i i just
stopped by and chat for an hour um so
uh
the board overhead for a public company
is much higher right i think some
investors probably worry about how your
time is being split and they would be
they might be excited by you know that
that's anyway i am i just i just woke up
the other day think thinking just there
are so many ways in which these things
connect and and and you know that just
the note the simplicity of that mission
of building a future that is worth
getting excited about might might appeal
to um an awful lot of people um
elon you
are reported by forbes and everyone
else's as now you know the world's
richest person that's not a sovereign
you know i think it's fair to say that
uh if somebody is like the
king or de facto uh
king of a country they're
wealthier than i am so but but it's just
harder to measure but what people do so
300 billion dollars i mean your your net
worth
on any given day is
rising or falling by several billion
dollars how inside how insane is that
yeah
i mean does that how do you how do you
handle that psychologically there aren't
many people in the world who have to
even think about that i i actually don't
think about that too much but the the
the thing that is actually more more
difficult and and that does make
sleeping difficult is
that um
you know every good hour
uh or even minute of thinking about uh
tesla
and spacex has such a big effect on the
company
that i really try to work as as much as
possible
you know to the edge of sanity basically
because the
you know tesla's getting to the point
where
uh
probably we'll get to the point later
this year where
every good every high quality minute of
thinking
um
is a million dollars to
impact on on tesla so
uh
which is insane um
so
um
i mean the basic you know if tesla is
doing
you know of a
sort of two billion dollars a week let's
say in revenues sort of 300
million dollars a day
seven days a week
you know it's
if you can change that by five percent
in an hour's brainstorm um
that those those are very valuable
that's a pretty valuable hour i mean
there are many many instances where a a
half hour meeting the finale i was able
to improve the financial outcome of the
company um by
100 million dollars in a half hour
meeting
there are many other people out there
who who who can't stand this world of of
billionaires like they are
hugely offended by the notion that
an individual
can have the same wealth as say a
billion or more of the the world's
poorest people
if if they examine sort of the sort of i
think there's some axiomatic flaws um
that that are leading to them to that
conclusion
if for sure it would be very problematic
if i was consuming uh
you know billions of dollars a year in
personal consumption but that is not the
case um in fact i don't even own a home
right now
i'm literally staying at friends places
i
if i travel to the bay area which where
most of tesla engineering is i stay in
my i basically rotate through friends
spare bedrooms um i don't have a yacht i
really don't take vacations uh so
um
it's not it's not as though there's um
that that my personal consumption is is
high uh
i mean the one exception is a plane but
if i don't use the plane then i have
less hours to work
so
um i mean i i personally think you have
shown that you are mostly driven by
really quite a deep sense of moral
purpose i like you you've tried your
your attempts to
solve
the climate problem have
have been as powerful as anyone else on
the planet that i'm aware of and i
actually can't understand personally i
can't understand the fact that you get
all this criticism from the left about
oh my god he's so rich that's disgusting
um when when climate is their issue
um philanthropy is a topic that some
people go to philanthropy is a hard
topic like how how do you think about
that
um i i think if you care about the
reality of goodness instead of the
perception of it
philanthropy is extremely difficult
spacex tesla neurolink boring company
are philanthropy if you say philanthropy
is love of humanity
they are philanthropy
they're
tesla is accelerating sustainable energy
this is a love of
full anthropy right
spacex is trying to ensure the long-term
survival of humanity with multi-planet
species this is love of humanity
um
you know neurolink is is to help solve
uh
brain injuries and uh existential risk
with ai love of humanity foreign company
is trying to solve traffic which is
health for most people and uh
that also it's like community it's like
how
how
upsetting is it to you to hear this
constant drum beat of
billionaires my god elon musk oh my god
like is that do you do you do you just
shrug that off or does it does it
actually hurt
i i mean at this point it's water if it
talks back
you know i'd like to as we wrap up now
just pull the camera back and just think
you're a father now of seven
surviving kids and and well i i mean i'm
trying to set a good example because the
birth rate on earth is so low that we're
facing civilizational collapse unless
the birth uh
sustainable level
yeah you've talked about this a lot that
depopulation is a big problem and we we
yes people don't understand population
collapse
is uh one of the biggest threats to the
future of human civilization and that is
what is going on right now how what what
drives you on a day-to-day basis to do
what you do
i guess
like i i really want to make sure that
there is a good future for humanity
and that we're on a path to
understanding the nature of the universe
um the meaning of life why are we here
how do we get here
um
and in order to
understand
the nature of the universe and
all these fundamental questions um
we must expand the scope and scale of
consciousness
uh
certainly it must not diminish or go out
or we we certainly wouldn't understand
this so i i always say i'm motivated by
curiosity more than anything
and
just a desire to think about the future
and
not be sad you know and um
and are you are you not sad
i'm sometimes sad i i mostly i'm i'm i
mean i'm feeling i guess
relatively optimistic about the future
these days
um there are certainly um some big risks
that humanity faces
uh i think the population collapse is a
really big deal that um i wish more
people would
would think about
um
because the birth rate is far below uh
what's needed to sustain civilization
it's current at its current level
and uh
you know there's obviously
we need to take action on
climate sustainability which is is being
done
um and we need to secure the future of
consciousness by being a multi-planet
species
we need to address the essentially we
it's important to take whatever actions
we can think of to address the
existential risks that affect the the
future of consciousness there's a
there's a whole generation coming
through who seem really sad about the
future what would you say
to them
well i think if you want the future to
be good you must make it so
take action
to make it good and it will be
elon thank you for all this time um that
is a beautiful place to end thanks for
all that you're doing you're welcome